Ginger armor is the daily moisturizing
mineral sunscreen perfect for any skin
type chemical sunscreens can cause
health issues including skin irritation
and stinging eyes but with ginger armors
ingredients from plants and minerals and
it being scent free and rubbing on
invisibly in seconds it's the best get
15 off with code Pacman using the link
below it is finally happening we are
going to get six years worth of Donald
Trump's tax returns after spending so
much time and so much money and so much
effort exhausting every possible means
the house Ways and Means Committee has
the tax returns and they have voted that
indeed they are going to release them
this is absolutely huge and we will talk
about what we might find in these tax
returns we already found out the
supposed audits that were taking place
we're not actually taking place we'll
delve into that in a moment Reuters
reporting U.S House committee to release
redacted Trump tax tax filings the U.S
House of Representatives committee voted
yesterday to release partially redacted
tax filings from Trump and said tax
authorities had failed to properly
scrutinize his returns while he was in
office despite endless breathless
apoplectic claims
that the IRS is working in a politically
partisan way to Target Republicans
Trump's filings were not even actually
scrutinized in the way he claimed that
they were the committee said the U.S
Internal Revenue Service did not follow
its own rules when it failed to audit
Trump's tax returns during three of his
four years in office
members said Congress should pass a law
to strengthen the presidential audit
program let's look at a video here of
Congressman Lloyd Doggett explaining
what we are going to get and when we are
going to get it that's going to be it
we're not also going to get all the tax
returns just to be very clear here you
will get all of the tax returns that the
Supreme Court and the lower courts said
that Mr Neal's request could get you
will get all of those uh that may be
delayed for a few days only to permit
permit time to redact things like Social
Security numbers uh personal ID numbers
that type of thing but you will get the
complete uh Trump tax return such as
they are
for the years that Mr Neal requested
okay so that's 20 2015 through 2020 just
to be clear yeah that's correct and I
think what uh I find surprising our
Focus had been on the IRS audit and
whether it was being done properly right
is the IRS did no audits at all
such time as the day they received Mr
Neal's request for these documents and
that day they requested the first audit
they have yet to complete a single audit
of Mr Trump can you imagine and we're
going to delve more into the audit part
but the critical question is at this
point in time what might we learn from
these tax returns amen a number of
different things Trump is not as wealthy
as he claims to be
almost certainly and in fact we have so
many other sources that suggest that is
the case we may learn about Trump's
conflicts of interest Trump's tax
returns could potentially reveal
conflicts between his business dealings
and his role as president of the United
States potentially conflicts of
interests uh with the National Security
consequence and it could include details
about financial arrangements with
foreign governments or individuals or
questionable relationships we could
learn about tax evasion or outright
fraud there have been concerns for a
long time about Trump's Financial
dealings including weather and it seems
almost guaranteed that he is from
everything else we know whether he is uh
misstating
exaggerating or understating the value
of certain assets for whatever purpose
is convenient at the time use of
charitable funds Trump has been
criticized for his use of funds from
charitable found from the charitable
Foundation which remember had its own
legal problems some years ago including
that he was using that money as a sort
of personal expense slush fund in the
tax returns it's possible that we might
learn more about that hidden assets
whether Trump has hidden assets or
income streams that have not been
previously disclosed and there is much
more why would Trump work so hard to
prevent the release of the tax returns
well based on the reasons I just gave
you there could be legal concerns in
other words if indeed Trump's tax
returns contain information about
possible fraud or any of the other
things I mentioned that could
potentially be used against Trump in a
legal context it could be the evidence
for the the tax evasion or fraud that he
has expected a suspected of engaging in
and that could be why he didn't want the
tax returns released image protection
Trump is extraordinarily Vain and
narcissistic the tax returns as I
mentioned might reveal Trump's not as
wealthy as he claims to be or that he is
debts that are maybe bad for his image
so image protection and thirdly to some
degree strategic considerations in the
sense that if he had normal followers
they might react to the information
contained in the tax returns negatively
and might abandon Trump doesn't have
normal followers we experience that
during 2016 and the phrase I could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and not lose any
support it actually seems much more
accurate than we might have assumed at
the beginning So in theory there would
be strategic considerations for Trump
wanting to prevent the release of his
tax returns in practice it's not clear
his followers really give to whatever's
uh about what the guy has done or
claimed or lied about or whatever the
case may be so we are days away maybe
even less
from the release of six years of Trump's
tax returns we will delve into it but
one thing we know the IRS audit claims
were lies I want to talk about that next
Trump has been caught lying he was not
being audited by the IRS in the way that
he claimed to be this so far we haven't
yet gotten the tax returns themselves
but we will based on the house Ways and
Means Committee vote yesterday we're
going to get the tax returns within a
few days maybe by the end of this week
maybe over the weekend maybe by the
start of of next week and we will deal
with that but one of the big takeaways
is that the IRS mandatory audits for
Trump when he became president were
essentially non-existent Trump lied
Sarah Huckabee Sanders lied and so many
of them lied let's go back to we looked
at some of this clip earlier
um Congressman Lloyd Doggett explained
Trump was not being audited I hope I'm
roughly at the right moment here uh
let's see exactly where we are here we
go 2015 through 2020 just to be clear
yeah that's correct okay and I think
what uh I find surprising this Focus had
been on the IRS audit and whether it was
being done properly is the IRS did no
audits at all until such time as the day
they received Mr Neal's request for
these documents and that day they
requested the first audit they have yet
to complete a single audit of Mr Trump
and I think they'll also be surprised by
what's not there with the tax returns
and that is supporting data any taxpayer
who goes in for audit has to produce
some receipts and some affidavits and
some substantiation and that just seems
to be missing from what we've been
providing that is absolutely fascinating
so even what they have obtained it seems
as though they really haven't gotten the
full data here is a congressman Richard
Neal who chairs the house Ways and Means
Committee expanding on this we argued
for an examination of how the audit
process played out
once
staff went to visit the IRS and once
staff had a chance to go to some of the
other locations that are within the
jurisdiction of the IRS
they quickly concluded that in fact
the audit did not occur there were no
audits in a timely manner and that goes
I think for 2017 2018 and 2019. and I'm
restrained by with the speech and debate
clause from talking about the other
issue that we uh
had on our agenda so the mandatory
initiative it highlights the idea that
it's sort of a two-tiered system if you
are at the top you really have no chance
of getting audited and as Steve
horsepower pointed out today in our our
get-together of the democratic caucus on
the committee your chances of being
audited if you claim the earned income
tax credit or far better than being
audited for people with the very top of
the economic system now that's an entire
other story we should talk about but
this claim that the IRS is targeting
Rich conservatives certainly does not
appear to be true and that's a bigger
story as a reminder here is Donald Trump
claiming that everything is under audit
and it's also complicated nobody would
understand it anyway this was at the end
of 2018 already
go ahead John
he gave me a fair interview the other
day so I might as well ask him a
question all right thank you Mr
President and pick you up there you told
me the other day that you are an open
book so I think I am an open book so
Point Blank Democrats go after your tax
returns will you try to block that or
will you allow them now well look as
I've told you they're under audit they
have been for a long time they're
extremely complex they wouldn't
understand them they're done by among
the biggest and best law firms in the
country same thing with the accounting
firms the accountants are a very very
large powerful firm from the standpoint
of respect extremely powerful from the
standpoint of respect don't forget that
be respected big firm
big and wide firm girthy a great law
firmware you would you know it very well
they do these things they put them in
but people don't understand tax returns
you know I did do a filing of over 100
pages I believe which is in the offices
and when people went and saw that filing
and they saw the magnitude of it they
were very disappointed and they cried
and they said sir there's so many pages
and such font well the you know the
details you'd get far more from that and
I guess we filed that down three times
but you get far more from that than you
could ever get from a tax return but
when you're under audit and I'm on a
very continuous audit because there are
so many companies and it is it's like a
Mobius strip of audits quite frankly
company far bigger than you would even
understand it's a bigger company than
you've got Jim it's a it's a great
company but it's big and it's complex
and it's uh probably feet high it's a
very complex instrument and I think that
uh people wouldn't understand it but I
don't know if a tax return is an
instrument but okay so there was Trump
talking about even if it's all under
audit continuous audit and it's too
complicated for you to even understand
and then here was uh then press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders also
making similar claims
foreign
here on taxes you said I think to Matt
on Tuesday that as long as his taxes are
under audit he's not going to release
them his 2016 taxes to our knowledge are
not under audit unless they are my
understanding uh and I will double check
but the president's taxes no matter who
the president is actually immediately go
under audit oh those are being filed so
that's actually wasn't happening though
were you an accurate I'll double check
to be one so my question is
so lies after lies after lies so I think
the strategy here
first we need to see what we learned
from the tax returns and that may modify
the strategy but absent the content
remember he said he would release his
tax returns when Obama releases his
birth certificate or whatever the birth
certificate we had the tax returns he
blocked he was going to release his
taxes if he won the presidency he won
the presidency in 2016 didn't release
the tax returns once the audits were
finished he was going to release him
turns out there weren't actually audits
going on so it's lie upon lie upon lie
we're going to get them we're going to
get them soon soon and we're going to
learn all about it folks Friday we are
two days away
from an incredible David packman Show
event we are doing
an end of the year membership special
where your first month's payment and
this applies to gifted memberships as
well will be donated
to an organization that sends cash to
people who need it one of the most
efficient ways of helping people is
actually sending them cash so they can
decide what for themselves what they
most need your first month's payment on
Friday if you use the coupon code we're
going to be creating
will be donated and doubled we're going
to be doubling the first fifteen
thousand dollars all you need to do to
be ready for Friday
is go to davidpackman.com
top right of the page it'll there's like
a box where you put in your email
address to get on our newsletter get on
our newsletter Friday morning you will
get instructions for how to sign up at a
discount we donate that first payment
and it gets doubled the first fifteen
thousand dollars incredible stuff we'll
take a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors today is ginger
armor the daily moisturizing mineral
sunscreen that's good for you and the
planet I've talked before about why I
only use mineral sunscreen instead of
chemical sunscreen I want a physical
barrier rather than chemicals absorbed
by the skin Ginger armor is an everyday
sunscreen moisturizer lip balm combo
that goes on lightweight unseen and
unscented perfect for all skin types
with powerful SPF 50 plus protection
rubs on invisibly in seconds no smell
feels good after shaving to stay
moisturized all day and the super
portable design is really good on the go
and it's made with 21 simple Earth
friendly ingredients from plants and
minerals unlike the chemical sunscreens
which can irritate skin worsen certain
conditions sting eyes Ginger armor is my
go-to for daily skin protection and
moisturizing even in Winter I know
you'll love it too it's also more
affordable than other mineral sunscreens
and it is a small business supporting
the David Pacman show go to
gingerarmor.com and use code Pacman for
15 off the link is below yesterday I
told you about the Republican
Congressman elect George Santos who got
caught lying about his employment
history and he got caught lying about
his educational history and he got
caught lying that he had four employees
that were victims of the Pulse Nightclub
shooting now George Santos has been
saying that he is a gay Jewish man and
it turns out that he does not appear to
be Jewish
I guess he's still
really gay we don't know but the Jewish
part seems to have also been part of his
completely made up story lgbtq Nation
reporting gay Jewish Republican
Congressman elect busted in another fake
claim he's probably not Jewish either
lgbtq Nation writes about a New York
Times piece
exploring all of the different lies that
he told about education and the other
things that we talked about and then it
goes on to say now another falsehood has
likely been exposed Santos touted his
Jewish Heritage to woo Orthodox Jewish
voters but Jewish telegraphic agency
reports that more than likely that is
fake too the outlet went back through
Santos's appearances and claims and
concluded that as with so much else in
his personal narrative there's little to
suggest truth Beyond his own past
comments Santos identifies as Jewish
through his mother although his father
was Catholic Santos has said that he is
Catholic that's common in America for
someone to identify as ethnically Jewish
and religiously Christian according to
the outlet both his parents are
Brazilian his biography includes the
info that George's grandparents fled
Jewish persecution in Ukraine settled in
Belgium and again fled persecution
during World War II
they ultimately settled in Brazil where
his mother was born sounds reasonable
Santos's mother Fatima devolder died in
New York City and her obituary doesn't
claim Jewish Heritage Fatima is a famous
Roman Catholic appellation for the
Virgin Mary what this means is
I've never met a Jew named Fatima that's
essentially what is being written here
devolder is a Flemish name validating
his Claim about Belgian Heritage but the
Flemish people are overwhelmingly
Catholic Santos's sister and his lawyer
all refused comment but Matt Brooks CEO
of the Republican Jewish Coalition told
the outlet he questioned the duplicitous
GOP Congressman elect I asked him about
this he identifies as Jewish so this
appears to be a lie as well now I don't
know it's not Stolen Valor but Stolen
Valor is something we talk about people
who claim military service when they
were not in the military or they say
well I had combat in the military when
they did not see combat in the military
this isn't Stolen Valor but it's
something else is applied to the Jewish
people and many of you know that I I'm
Jewish Jewish Heritage and identity and
ethnicity
are really closely tied to the culture
and history of the Jewish people and the
oppression of Jewish people for 2000
years and for a lot of Jews it's an
important part of our identity and so
when you see someone that is claiming
this and it is made up in this case
potentially to woo
uh Orthodox Jewish voters you are
attempting to profit from a story that
has a lot of tragedy and it has a lot of
horrible things that affects and guides
how Jewish people feel today
without actually having that in your
family history without actually having
lived it and the sum total of the lies
that this guy has told in any normal job
would get you fired uh I mean it in
normal jobs if it was uncovered after
you were hired by HR that you lied about
your employment history and you lied
about it your educational history you
know the Jewish thing is more of an from
an employment standpoint it's less
relevant to claim that you were Jewish
when you were not but the sum totality
of this in any normal job would get you
fired and this is a guy who I I can't
imagine that I mean he was vote they
voted for him they voted for him maybe
based on some lies if he had said hey
you know what
I actually don't really have any
relevant employment history or
impressive education and I don't share
an identity with the Orthodox Jewish
voters and I
it's possible that he might have lost of
course it is too late at this point in
time but uh starting starting off strong
an incredibly historic level of
dishonesty from a guy that was
celebrated by many including by people
like Glenn Greenwald look it's
Republicans electing a gay congressman
and blah blah blah blah seems like he
made everything up the last thing would
be is he actually gay and I couldn't
care less one way or the other he's a
liar that's what I care about but it
seems for now that is the one part of
his claimed uh person uh uh personal
description that remains true hey you've
got to see this fox host Jesse Waters
tried to confront a satanic temple
leader Lucian Graves who we've had on
the program before and it went really
really really poorly
um Jesse Waters and others on Fox News
love to go after the satanic temple and
the satanic temple you know some people
say the satanic temp temple is a
satirical religion but the truth is it's
really no more or less satirical than
any other religion and this is sort of
the point that you don't get to say well
the satanic temple it's not like
Christianity no it actually kind of is
and so Jesse Waters brings on Lucian
Graves and he seems to think that he's
going to steamroll him and he doesn't
and it's very very interesting take a
look at this
well we still have some questions so
let's ask the satanic temple
spokesperson Lucian Greaves all right
first of all Lucian Grieves it's Lucian
Graves it's not a particularly difficult
name to say Lucian if Satan is evil I
thought nice to meet you too if Satan's
evil why should kids be in an evil Club
well obviously we don't view Satan as
evil and it really doesn't matter to us
what your mythology is surrounding Satan
you need to ask yourself if your
distaste over us identifying as Satanist
is strong enough that you would abandon
the principles of free speech in
religious liberty I always thought Satan
was like sex you know like when you're
18 Satan sex do your thing but I don't
know if I would want Satan in schools
you understand how parents feel right
well parents can feel that way and many
parents feel similarly about Evangelical
after-school clubs and in fact we put
our club in place to offer an
alternative against Evangel in an
Evangelical Club that's explicitly
designed to convert children and get
them to proselytize to other kids so if
parents don't want to send their kids to
an after-school Satan Club they can send
them to an Evangelical Club there's
other religious clubs really I think the
controversy just evades the issue as to
whether or not we're willing to allow
government functionaries at school
boards or whatever to Simply shut down
somebody's religious liberty or Free
Speech because they don't like it so
you're kind of doing it to tweak the
system I get it what are these tenets of
Satanism can you enlighten me
yeah I think the tenants are very
pro-social they're almost Universal I
would think and and I think as time goes
on we'll kind of converge on a consensus
morality but as but we don't have to I
mean people we're not looking to convert
people into Satanism we're not even
teaching children about Satanism in
classes well give me a tenant
one should strive to act with compassion
and empathy with it to All Creatures
within reason
oh that sounds fine all right uh you
might like it yeah maybe I don't know
about all that are you married by the
way
uh no I'm not no okay I just I was just
wondering all right so you're probably
gonna go to hell right
I I don't believe in hell we're a
non-theistic religious group all right I
thought maybe you wanted to go to hell
Idaho what do I know I need to learn
more about seeing a better party than
Heaven Fox News promoted this as a
grilling of Lucian Graves that Jesse
Waters really grilled him
the one substantive point that came up
which is Lucian explaining how others
should be treated based on the satanic
Temple's view Jesse agreed with and then
he switched to are you married I guess
to just ridicule him and based on I
don't even know and say no of course you
couldn't find a wife or husband who
knows you know I mean you have one place
where all the Sexes kind of go after
they live a
solvent known interesting life how it
might might be okay all right we gotta
go
um I'm probably gonna butcher your name
again
almost had it thank you very much have a
great night yeah so Fox News promotes
that as a grilling and really the
interesting thing here is every time
that the satanic temple stuff comes up
and again my view is I'm not a satanic
temple member and I'm not Christian but
I don't really see any difference and
the condescension from and that there's
many Christians that have interviewed
Lucian The condescension about your
religion it's it's nothing like ours
like our our thing is real your thing
isn't real it's either evil or it's a
parody and a joke
substantively speaking and it very
importantly in the eyes of the law and
this applies to after school programs as
well there really is not a distinction
now I I do think that where you would
start to go over a line is if there is a
a religious group
um and they want to have an after school
program and there's they're like openly
advocating for violence or murder and by
the way I mean what's crazy is there are
Evangelical churches recently that have
advocated for violence against people
who support for example abortion being
legal so like it actually happens and
they don't get in trouble but if things
were sensible I could see arguing that a
particular religion maybe shouldn't be
allowed to have an after-school group if
it could be proven that they're really
just advocating for physical violence
and they're teaching kids to you know go
out and attack people or something like
that
beyond that to pass these moral
judgments or to create tears of religion
based solely on the number of followers
that they have and certainly there are
more Christians than Satanic Temple
members really misses the point of the
framework of how this country is
organized and Jesse Waters and people
like him
seem to from a starting point assume
that of course Christianity is in a
different category than the satanic
temple when it really isn't and so Fox
News promoted that as a grilling I
didn't see much of a grilling let me
know your thoughts make sure you're
subscribed to our YouTube channel there
are more than three million of you who
watch our Clips but don't subscribe my
request is hit that subscribe button
it's free and it really helps us
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
what is forthcoming in terms of criminal
charges for former president Donald
Trump we are really getting into the
meat of this now as we see criminal
referrals from the January 6 house
committee the Georgia investigation the
tax returns possibly exposing tax fraud
and evasion are coming out within days
there is one opinion that is an
interesting one which is from former
Watergate prosecutor Nick Ackerman who
expects Donald Trump to face both state
and federal charges what would happen if
that took place we will discuss but
first let's look at what Nick Akerman
had to say on CNN yesterday and his
production predictions are very clear
and they sound confident now remember
many times people say things confidently
and they're wrong so take that uh
consideration what do you think happens
that's what everyone wants to know
Donald Trump is going to be indicted
he's going to be indicted in Georgia and
I think he's going to be indicted by the
feds I think they've got the evidence we
don't know exactly what a lot of these
cooperating Witnesses are saying uh and
I think that um you've got someone like
Mark Meadows who's probably the weak
link and if you're looking for the one
witness the most likely to turn I would
vote him the most likely to turn okay
what do you think so
if this happened
what happens in the United States
because this would be a very very very
big deal
if a former president were to be
indicted
there would be a number of issues that
would have to be overcome first and
foremost
who sits on the jury and as I've said
before if you had someone like Trump in
front of a jury how do you find a jury
that is not going to be subject to
appeal because of the preconceived
notions and biases of those jurors there
are very few people in the United States
who don't have a strong opinion about
Donald Trump either for or against and
if you find the people who genuinely
don't have an opinion they are usually
acutely and painfully uninformed people
that I would also worry about having on
a jury simply due to their ability to
understand what the hell is going on if
I'm able to speak candidly with you so I
do think that the jury question is a
major major question but long before you
even got to that it's important to
understand
the framework around criminal charges
for a president of the the United States
first you have to understand the legal
immunity component while a president is
President there is significant legal
immunity from prosecution for certain
actions that are taken as part of their
official duties there are disagreements
among the legal Community if not
connected to their presidential duties a
president while president went and
committed some kind of cold-blooded
murder are they subject to prosecution
you can find legal opinions on both
sides of that question but that's not
actually what we're talking about right
now and that immunity extends to certain
actions taken after a president leaves
office but how far that goes is also a
subject of legal debate there are
political considerations because the
prosecution and theoretically the
conviction of a former president on
criminal charges
is undoubtedly going to be a politicized
event and that can make it
extraordinarily difficult for
prosecutors to actually get a conviction
and if you do get one you could have
serious problems as I mentioned in terms
of who was on that jury and the jury
selection and it's very
finding someone guilty in the court of
public opinion is a very different thing
than finding legal guilt Beyond a
reasonable Beyond A Reasonable Doubt uh
in a criminal court you also have a
burden of proof issue when going after a
former president you have that in
general but in order to get a conviction
on criminal charges prosecutors do need
to establish the defendant's guilt
beyond that Reasonable Doubt in general
that's a tough standard in the American
legal system that's why we have many
acquittals but when the defendant is a
former president with access to every
resource and advisors and the best
lawyers that can also be a significant
challenge to overcome and also these
things move slowly Trump has been out of
office now for just short of two years
and the passage of time can make it more
difficult to secure convictions on
criminal charges if there's a lot of
distance from when the alleged crime
took place and this can be because of
inability to locate Witnesses who
remember relevant issues or a loss of
evidence or for a whole number of other
reasons and also it's important to
consider that public sentiment can
change George W bush is a good example
of this and I've been careful on this
program never to
rehabilitate George W Bush's image while
acknowledging like okay he's not as
whacked As Trump in a lot of different
ways right after George W bush left
office if you were to pull the American
public I think you would have found that
there was significant support for going
after Bush as a war criminal for his
actions related to the Iraq War my
belief is and this is just speculation
and maybe there's polling on this I
don't know that if you pulled the
country now on that exact same question
you would find much less support for
going after Bush for war crimes even
though the actions taken while he was
President don't differ now this is
different than was he immune because
these were actions taken in Iraq related
to his work it's not it's not even a
legal question it's just a public
opinion question I believe that although
the facts haven't changed since George W
bush left office
the interest from the public in going
after Bush for whatever wrongdoing he
may have participated it in would have
been greatly diminished and I do think
that the longer that this goes without
charges against Trump that is
potentially also going to be a factor so
Nick acreman says legal uh criminal
charges coming at the state and federal
level
we will probably soon know as so many
things are now happening at once Donald
Trump's ethics lawyer allegedly told a
witness to the January 6 Trump Riot
committee
to lie under oath this is absolutely
unbelievable CNN has an exclusive report
Trump's former White House ethics lawyer
told Cassidy Hutchinson to give
misleading testimony to the January 6th
committee according to multiple sources
look at this
the January 6th committee made a
startling allegation on Monday claiming
it had evidence that a trump-backed
attorney
urged a key witness to mislead the
committee about details they recalled
though the committee declined to
identify the people CNN has learned that
Stefan passantino the top ethics
attorney in the Trump White House is the
lawyer who allegedly advised his then
client former White House aide Cassidy
Hutchinson to tell the committee that
she did not recall details that she did
recall source is familiar with the
committee's work tell CNN
um Trump save America Pac funded
pastantino and his Law Firm elections
LLC including paying for his
representation of Hutchinson other
sources tell CNN the committee report
notes the lawyer did not tell his client
who was paying for the legal services
when asked about pressure on Hutchinson
after Monday's hearing Committee Member
representative zoloftgren told CNN she
was advised to say she didn't recall
something when she did so that's pretty
serious stuff the episode is just one of
several instances in which the committee
has accused members of Trump's orbit of
trying to obstruct the panel's
investigation
this is extraordinarily serious if true
if a lawyer were to tell a congressional
witness to lie under oath it could
potentially constitute the crime of
perjury or the related offense of
suborning of perjury or maybe it's
subordination of perjury
which is the act of inducing someone to
commit perjury and it's important to
note that the specific legal
consequences of that depend on the
details of the case the applicable law
the circumstances what you can prove is
as often the case when it comes to
perjury etc etc now you and I of course
recognize the kind of oxymoronic nature
of a trump ethics lawyer I I get that
we're not even going to focus in on that
but this is sort of like a third layer
of what is going on with the Trump riots
because you have sort of at the top of
the food chain as the case may be at the
top of the pyramid is the riot itself
and who was involved in inciting and the
planning of that Riot that's number one
number two is you have the witnesses
at the Trump Riot committee hearings and
whether they told the truth or lied
whether they were tampered with Etc
the third layer now is were there other
people
influencing the testimony of the
witnesses at the January 6 Committee
hearing about the Trump riots and who
incited those so you've got like Trump
inciting the riot and then you've got
Cassidy Hutchinson testifying about what
she saw in terms of who was inciting or
talking about or trying to dissuade the
writers and now we have a third level
which is who influenced Cassidy
Hutchinson's testimony and potentially
told her to say she doesn't recall
things that she actually does recall
about that top layer of the pyramid we
now have three layers to this pyramid
the fourth layer
maybe is like the rioters themselves in
some way it starts to get
extraordinarily complicated but this is
already
above and beyond anything that we have
seen in the history of the United States
part of the difference is in an era of
records for communication and text
messages an event that was on camera and
on and on that makes it different in
terms of our ability to actually see and
figure out what went on and that's
understandable but there has never been
anything like this in American history
and so we are going to at some point uh
see if and when the justice department
decides to act on those criminal
referrals that have already been sent
forward and that applies to Donald Trump
as we learned earlier this week John
Eastman the lawyer and others but
there's this whole other layer which is
what about all of the perjury that is
suspected among some of the witnesses
and then who got to them and was there
indeed witness tampering one of the
things that was also alleged during
maybe it was the second to last or what
one of the kind of later public hearings
of the January 6 committee was that
there were individuals there were
multiple instances of individuals
reaching out to Witnesses and allegedly
trying to intimidate or tamper I don't
believe we ever actually fully got to
the bottom of that I don't think this
example is the the full scope of that
and that's just another layer that needs
to be investigated unfortunately the
January 6 committee is going to end
because this session of Congress is
ending and then Republicans are taking
over they don't want to look into the
riots they want to look into stuff like
the genitalia of Hunter Biden and stuff
like that so things are going to change
dramatically but we will hopefully get
to the bottom of this component and
again Trump ethics lawyer I don't know
of any uh greater oxymoron than that
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I want to
have a brief uh update with you about
what's going on in Arizona and in
America Fest and with the Arizona
gubernatorial election it's actually
becoming even more cartoonish and
pathetic and humiliating than what we
saw after the 2020 election with Donald
Trump Carrie Lake who lost the 2022
Arizona gubernatorial election that's it
there's no other there's that's the
story she lost her opponent got more
votes she is now calling for a new
election and there are people around her
who seem to be encouraging her we're
going to go to our first clip this is
from the the last whimpers of America
Fest an event put on by turning point
USA here is Carrie Lake speaking to
Charlie Kirk and they now want a new
election in Arizona
all that happened is Carrie Lake lost
understand that what is the remedy we're
asking for I think that we need a new
election I think that there needs to be
a new election
but we can't have the same clowns
running this election we can't put it
back into the hands of people who have
bungled the election time and time again
and yes now that's there's an important
little detail in there which is in some
alternate universe which we might enter
in the next clip I'm going to show you
by the way but in some alternate
universe where you get a new election
you know that if they did the election
and then Kerry Lake lost again they
would just say
the same people ran this election this
election was just as biased and
fraudulent and rigged as the first one
and we know that that would happen
because it's what it's what we see when
they do recounts and audits every single
time you get an audit to the ex and
again when you say an audit what is it
that they want
they do an audit and it turns out the
result was fine or even that the
Democrat actually won by more and then
they come back and they say that wasn't
really an audit
all they did was recount the same
fraudulent ballots we need signature
verification we need curing we need
sauteing and smoking and Grilling we
need to do all these things to the
ballots uh to figure out whether these
should even be counted because at the
end of the day
they will adjust their allegation of
what happened
simply to fit whatever narrative they
need at that moment at one point the
problem in Arizona was people didn't get
to vote and that hurt Carrie Lake
because of tabulators and power circuits
and all these different printers people
who wanted to vote didn't get to vote
then the story shifted to so many people
voted in Arizona who shouldn't even have
voted and it was and tons of Republicans
voted and their votes were counted for
Katie Hobbs wait a second was the
problem that Republicans weren't able to
vote or was the problem that Republicans
were able to vote in huge numbers but
tons of their votes were counted with
Katie hops which of the two is actually
the problem
and it's both depending on what's going
on one other really funny moment from
this interview with Charlie Kirk Carrie
Lake explains her process for hiring
attorneys and it's it's pretty damn
funny and it was a valley-wide Ambush is
what happened absolutely absolutely 100
and and they're trying to tell us this
is normal par for the core don't insult
Hey Stephen Richard don't insult my
intelligence we know what you're up to
and we're gonna we're gonna put you on
the stand and ask you a few tough
questions so right I feel very confident
my team is great my attorneys are true
Patriots we had attorneys who did walk
away because the left is threatening
them with their ability to make a living
and practice law and some of our
attorneys said look I got mouths to feed
I can't do this case I don't want to be
sanctioned so I I really love I I got to
a point where I said I'll take anybody
we'll take Better Call Saul come on
are you a patriot are you willing to
fight are you willing to risk everything
on this very important case and that's
who we have assembled true Fighters and
we're going to court tomorrow and
Thursday and we hope for a quick uh you
know ruling yeah it's evident that
absolutely anyone can be Carrie Lake's
lawyer that that we've figured out and
that is abundantly clear so uh there's
not going to be a new election Katie
Hobbs is going to be the governor of
Arizona Katie Hobbs won Kerry Lake loss
but before we completely get off of this
topic I have to show you someone who
truly does seem to be living in an
alternate universe I'm going to play a
clip for you now of Arizona senator
Wendy Rogers saying that right now yes
December 2022
Kerry lake is the governor-elect of the
State of Arizona now of course Kerry
lake is not the governor-elect of the
State of Arizona I think you probably
know that but what is fascinating about
this is
I don't think Wendy Rogers really thinks
Carrie lake is the governor-elect of
Arizona and I don't think Stephen Bannon
who's conducting this interview really
thinks Carrie lake is the governor-elect
of Arizona what's fascinating is about
this is that it seems to just be sort of
like a power game
does Bannon have the power
to get Wendy Rogers to say something
that they both know of course isn't true
who wields the power in this Dynamic and
it seems that it's Bannon take a look at
this this is unbelievable problem and uh
we need to get to the bottom of all of
this and I just telling you we're not
having it anymore we're done as Carrie
said
as Kerry said you're messing with the
wrong people
[Music]
is Kerry Lake the governor of left of
Arizona yes
is there any doubt in your mind
[Applause]
you have an even stronger mandate and
she told me about a week ago she said
you know Wendy
um
by the way if you're watching this
bannon's co-host is so bored she's just
texting on her phone when I might have
assumed office had I been elected
properly without all this aftermath
maybe we would have had a honeymoon
period with everybody maybe we would
have had a transition time of you know
let's all get along no all right no that
that ship sailed okay so what we're
doing now is we're going to in the
Senate and in the house we're going to
legislate and then we will work with her
to get it all done and people ask me oh
Senator will you take a meeting for this
or that I go no not until I know who the
governor is amen
so of course maybe this is evidence of a
Multiverse insofar as maybe maybe there
is a parallel universe
in which Kerry lake is the
governor-elect of Arizona but the
universe you and I occupy is not one in
which that is the term that applies to
Carrie lay you know you can uh pray to
Jesus Wish Upon a Star pull out a Ouija
board get a divining Rod start chugging
Homeopathy I don't know you could do
whatever you want Reiki
um it's not going to make Carrie Lake be
the governor-elect of Arizona
um at another point during this very
same interview
Steve Bannon and Wendy Rogers call on
people to get themselves arrested over
Kerry Lake's election I should not throw
out right this was intentionally done to
suppress the vote of Carrie Lake
supporters and mega voters in Maricopa
County on Game Day correct yes and so
we're talking what we what I want to see
is people arrested right
very strong arrests
do you think do you think uh Colonel
Rogers would be like Judge Roy beam
right she's a hanging judge right get
some air budget and not throw out right
unbelievable stuff and by the way
when someone like Bannon gets arrested
which by the way happened
he's got the money for a great legal
defense and they're gonna make it so
that he goes to you know the cushiest
prison and all this different stuff when
the people that watch this crap
follow the advice and they go out there
and they get themselves arrested they're
the ones that get stuck in pre-trial
detention they're the ones with the
public defenders and
public defenders can be great they're
just totally overworked and they don't
they just don't have the time to devote
to all the cases that are handed to them
and all these different things they
don't care about you at that point in
time and Marjorie Taylor green will make
a show out of going to visit you at some
jail and saying it's also unfair it's
unfair it's unfair but your experience
when you get arrested on their say-so is
going to be very different than their
experience when they get arrested one
other sad slash funny moment
um is just that this this co-host in the
pink dress on the right of the screen
she just is so bored with everything she
just texts the entire show look at her
unseat Rana McDaniel because she's
failed us okay real quickly give us that
again you've got to get
with the precinct committee man your
Precinct chair and and make sure
eventually you get up to the two
committee there's one committee man and
committee woman for each state correct
yes there's a committee woman in
committee state but the thing listen if
I was sitting there listening to Steve
Bannon dronen about this I've I'd
probably be texting someone as well but
just a horrible pathetic but also
extraordinarily dangerous situation
they're just straight up lying Kerry
Lake not the governor-elect of Arizona
she's not going to be governor of
Arizona for now maybe she'll run in the
future maybe she'll win in the future
but right now Katie Hobbs one thankfully
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a really great
question about how to deal with people
who do a certain really annoying thing
during political debates and
conversations take a listen
hey David uh sir this is Jose I just had
a quick question yes I was wondering if
you had any advice to what you would
tell somebody if you're having a
discussion with them about politics
where they just immediately go to what
about him they don't really bring
anything to the conversation they just
say what about this what about that what
about this yep just need some help uh
just with that thank you so this is
super common the way it might go is you
say listen the evidence is
indicative that Trump committed crimes
and should be charged and then the
person you're talking to goes well what
about Hunter bite
understand that sometimes when people do
the what about this other thing
it's because their brain is scrambled
and I'm not saying this to make fun of
people but what I mean is there are lots
of people who they don't organize their
thoughts in their head
and they can't think straight and so
they're just bouncing all over the place
and it's sort of like a cognitive issue
of getting them to actually focus in on
the one thing you're trying to talk
about that's one category you then also
have people who use what about ISM as
deliberate deception or to try to
undermine or distract and create red
herrings they use it sort of like as a
tool
uh very deliberately and in bad faith
and then you've got people who it's not
that their brain is totally scrambled
and they're not completely bad faith
they're just kind of like a little
ignorant and they don't realize that
there's all these separate issues and
and we we should deal with these issues
one at a time so Step One is sort of try
to figure out if the person doing the
what about ism is doing it for one or
the other of those possibilities that I
mentioned bad faith brain scrambled sort
of confused try to figure that out and
one of the best tools that I find when
somebody brings out this other thing
that they want to talk about is to say
hey you know what that may also be a
problem I'm glad to talk about that but
let's stick with this topic first
resolve it and then we can talk about
that other thing very quickly you'll
know if you say something like that when
the what about ISM pops up whether
you're dealing with a brain scramble or
someone functioning in bad faith or
someone who's just a little bit confused
and sometimes they'll say oh you know
what you're right okay yeah let's figure
this thing out first then we can talk
about that other thing another
tool these aren't even really tools
these are literally just one liners to
try to refocus the conversation another
thing that can sometimes be said when
the what about ISM pops up is something
along the lines of can we just decide
and agree what we're talking about now I
know there's all these different things
we can talk about you're wanting to talk
about something different let's just
agree what we're now talking about and
oftentimes it'll get the other person to
have to actually tell you what it is
we're talking about and if they're doing
a what about ISM with something that
really isn't related but what about that
time when Obama drew a red line in Syria
doesn't really have anything to do with
the Qatari World Cup does it right the
example sometimes that will also get
people refocused because you're letting
them decide what you're talking about
and sometimes it'll become evident that
the two things aren't related if you're
trying to talk about criminal charges
against Trump and they want to talk
about Obama's red line and you say can
you just tell me what are we talking
about right now just so we can finish
that it's going to be hard for them to
go well we're talking about criminal
charges against Trump and Obama's Red
Line in Syria a lot of people when they
say that out loud would go wait a second
that those two things aren't even
remotely connected that doesn't make any
sense okay so some ideas for dealing
with the what aboutists Friday December
23rd we are doing a one-day membership
special hugely discounted last one of
the Year remember we're an independent
media show and we're funded by our
viewers but we're going to do something
extra
we are going to donate your first
month's discounted payment when you sign
up Friday with a coupon code that is
forthcoming we will donate that first
month's payment to charity to be sent as
cash to people in need I'm talking about
people for whom a few bucks makes a big
difference people living on a dollar a
day people living on two dollars a day
in different parts of the world we've
never done this before and we have an up
to fifteen thousand dollar match so if
you have a six dollar a month membership
coupon code smacks it down to three
dollars a month we will donate your
three dollars and we will match it with
another three dollars we've never tried
this we're trying to do something for
the people
uh if you want to be notified about this
it'll be in an email that goes out
Friday morning
get on my newsletter at davidpackman.com
it's free to get on it you just type in
your email address at the top right of
the page and Friday you will get all of
the details on today's bonus show
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is coming to the U.S he may
already be here he will be addressing
Congress tonight it is a big deal when a
foreign leader addresses Congress we
will talk about it Elon Musk will resign
as head of Twitter and many of you wrote
to me and said this is great news a few
of you wrote to me and said this is bad
news they're going to install a flunky
he'll do all the same terrible things
and then Elon Musk can say I'm not even
in charge anymore and shift blame we'll
talk about it and we are also going to
talk about the confusion and the
falsehoods that have been spreading
in China as China has reversed its
so-called zero coveted policy which of
course didn't really lead to zero covet
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com we
will see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors Ginger armor is
the daily moisturizing mineral sunscreen
perfect for any skin type chemical
sunscreens can cause health issues
including skin irritation and stinging
eyes but with ginger armors ingredients
from plants and minerals and it being
scent free and rubbing on invisibly in
seconds it's the best get 15 off with
code Pacman using the link below